all right guys bang bang got Darius here
Darius Global liquidity we have been
talking about it now for weeks it looks
like we have finally bottomed but the
recovery is not so much a linear thing
or is it how do you look at the global
liquidity right now yeah hey man what's
up it's good to see you guys um so I'll
start by saying we've had a significant
increase off the lows in global
liquidity uh if you're already chart
number one what I'm showing in this
first chart is our Global liquidity
proxy that's the Blue Line in the top
panel uh for those who are maybe not
unfamiliar uh how we track Global
liquidity 42 macro uh we aggregate the
US dollar some of the global central
bank balance sheet Global broad money
supply and Global FX reserves minus gold
for a variety of different reasons we
include those measures but the one thing
we'd say is if you look at the middle
panel there where we show the max
drawdown study for the blue line which
again is our Global liquidity proxy you
know it recovered significantly off the
lows of late 2024 2022 but as you can
see in recent weeks and months it had
that recovery process is really stalled
out and we're actually moving in the
wrong direction so this is something
we've been calling out in our research
we started making noise about this in
kind of in the late April right around
the year to date highs in Bitcoin and
we've not recovered that price we've
obviously haven't really crashed lower
but in our view a lot of it's kind of
weighed on the the price of Bitcoin and
really all digital assets relative to
like us equities is the fact that we've
seen this uh non-linear recovery process
and Global liquidity so when you start
looking at asset markets obviously these
asset markets are a key piece to it
there's kind of the response to the
liquidity if you will how are you
looking at uh asset markets and and what
is that response yeah great question so
the next chart we have for the viewers
we have our Global liquidity proxy on
the top panel with respect to the S P
500 price and the Bitcoin price and what
we show in the kind of the second third
and fourth panels there is a trailing
one-year z-score study so we're
normalizing uh these uh these measures
to kind of make them a little bit more
comparable and what you see is that if
you look at a one year z-score of our
Global liquidity proxy it's only at
about a 0.2 Sigma relative to its uh
trailing one year mean whereas the S P
500 is a plus 2.36 plus 2.2 Sigma and
Bitcoin is a plus 1.1 Sigma so we're
seeing a lot of bigger recovery on a
normalized basis in asset markets
relative to the recovery we've seen in
global liquidity which again is now
moving in the wrong direction
so when we start looking at Global
liquidity impulse that is something kind
of a little bit different you have to
explain to people what exactly the
impulse component is and then what are
you seeing there yeah absolutely so just
a simple simplistic uh we use big
jargony words in finance but the reality
is all we're tracking is trialing
through muscle momentum uh in these time
series uh to identify with the impulse
is positive or not you can obviously
pick your own duration but we try to
protracted trailing through mods seems
to be the best in terms of fitting this
with asset markets um and so as we sew
again our Global liquidity proxy in the
top panel of this chart relative to
World Equity market cap and as you can
see we're kind of flat falling through
month basis and Global liquidity had
been very positive right if you go back
to the lows amount or sorry it had been
very had been very negative then it
became very positive now we're kind of
flat and so if you go back to the um the
lows of 2022 last year you know we had a
minus six trillion dollar trailing
through Mountain impulse uh in the month
of um in the month of October and that's
obviously it's a pretty significant uh
decline but that kind of swung all the
way around to a plus nine trillionish
dollar impulse positive impulse by the
time we got into q1 of this year and
that positive impulse has been steadily
waning um on a trailing three-month
basis until we got to kind of um April
and May and which is now flat so
um this is not the equity Market sort of
mirror this from the perspective of
um you know the the the the momentum in
the impulse itself so the momentum of
the momentum but the reality is we're
still growing in equity Market terms uh
and which is uh not necessarily
something uh you know that we feel is
sustainable now one of the nuances when
we start looking at this is there's
public sector and private sector
liquidity and sometimes they move in uh
kind of concert with each other other
times they do not right now it appears
they're not so explain the differences
between public sector and private sector
and then why are they almost operating
at the opposite ends of the spectrum
right now yeah absolutely so I'll start
by saying the reason we look at Global
liquidity in terms of our Global
liquidity proxy again central bank
balance sheet Global broad money supply
Global FX reserves minus gold is to sort
of identify you know inflection points
in the liquidity cycle by isolating you
know kind of key factors so private
sector liquidity which is liquidity
created by commercial Banks tends to be
very pro-cyclical if growth's
accelerating the liquidity is going to
be accelerating if growth decelerating
liquidity is going to be decelerating
you know Banks effectively extend credit
non-bank you know Financial Market
participants extend credit when things
are getting better they pull back on
credit intermediation when things are
getting worse so we understand that this
is a very key component of liquidity
private sector liquidity in terms of
exacerbating Trends but what causes the
trends to inflect are is the public
sector liquidity function I.E central
banks what's happening with respect to
Central Bank policy so that's why they
you know we spend so much time talking
about central banks as Market
participants because ultimately they can
cause an inflection either to the upside
from a negative Trend or an inflection
the downside from a positive trend with
respect to private sector liquidity and
then obviously broad liquidity when you
Mega made all these measures and so
right now what's happening we're seeing
a modest increase in private sector
liquidity on a trailing firm of momentum
basis again that's the the bottom panels
in these charts uh and then when you see
the um we're also seeing a negative uh
trolling through mouth impulse in in
global private sector liquidity so the
private sector liquidity impulse is very
much kind of mirroring the decisive as
we have a recession in the Arizona
economy we have a disappointing uh
recovery in the Chinese economy that's
kind of inflected uh negatively from an
Impulse perspective in recent months in
the most recent month and then obviously
growth has been slowing in the U.S
although albeit still very much not in
the recession so that's kind of one
thing we call out but again don't forget
the global liquidity impulse traveling
through your month is flat it's flash
it's moving lower on a kind of a
sequential basis and ultimately we
expect that kind of trailing through
month impulse to get that negative that
flat trailing three month impulse to go
negative in the coming months so let's
go around the world here we can go east
to west let's start with China and kind
of the liquid there what are you seeing
yeah absolutely so China is uh we're
kind of you know bucking the trend if
you as it relates to Global liquidity so
right now the Chinese um liquidity and
Pulsa that's uh chart five there uh is
actually currently negative only
modestly negative but they've done a
series of measures in recent weeks that
gives us confidence to say that that
minus that might that modest negative
impulse is likely to inflect positive uh
in the coming months so they cut their
um seven day their Benchmark seven day
reverse repurchase rate by 10 basis
points the pboc did last week they also
cut their one-year medium-term lending
facility rate by 10 basis points last
week we've seen fall through by Chinese
Banks this week
um they're cutting their um one year and
five-year loan Prime rates by 10 basis
points and you know this kind of mirrors
the the series of easing measures we saw
kind of in the middle to the second half
of 2022 that really helped the Chinese
liquidity impulse kind of um inflect
positively alongside obviously a lot of
um pboc open market operations and
medium-term lending uh financing itself
and so that's something we would expect
to see over the coming coming months and
and obviously would be a positive from a
global liquidity perspective given how
dominant China the Chinese economy is in
that in that um in that Matrix but the
issue there is that you have you know
liquidity impulses in the US is likely
to deepen uh the negative liquidity
impulse in the US is likely to deepen uh
in the coming months uh Eurozone is as
likely to inflect negative in Japan
potentially May um become negative and
deepen as well so we can unpack each of
those separately let's go now to the
United States and their liquidity what
are you seeing there and it almost feels
like it's going to be opposite of China
yeah absolutely so clearly I mean our
liquidity cycle has been negative for
for quite a while now it's not no secret
to anyone if that's obviously doing
quantitative tightening um you know
clear clearly we have an issue in the
banking sector as it relates to Extended
credit
um certainly not extending credit nearly
at the pace that we had been uh in
recent quarters um and so that's likely
to get worse in our view uh for a couple
of reasons one we have clearly the
rebuild of the TGA we've talked about
this months ago so it's not no secret I
think it's pretty consensus now um
that's the drain liquidity at the margin
it's because we have not seen the
decline in the reverse rural facility
balance fully offset the rise in the TGA
you know treasury secretary young which
is something we've talked about maybe a
month or two ago on the program it did a
good job of kind of concentrating
um t-bill issuance you know kind of a
really you know hitting the market heavy
and hard with t-bill issue it's a very
short dated TBL issuance to kind of
drain a lot of funds out of the feds
reverse remote facilities program and
transition those into the TGA so that's
obviously offset the rise and the
potential drain and liquidity that we've
seen in the rise in terms of the rise of
the TGA post debt selling that that
process is not being fully offset so at
the margins you're seeing a little bit
of decline in liquidity in the U.S but
what I think is the bigger issue and the
more structural issue is the fact that
we're running with these sort of record
non-war non-recession budget deficits in
the US economy we are currently tracking
at minus eight percent of GDP as it
relates to our budget deficit as a um as
a percent of nominal GDP that's the most
recent month this may that we have the
data for and so what that ultimately
means is that they're going to be
issuing a lot of debt regardless and the
reason we bring this up is because the
FED has been doing quantitative
tightening on autopilot in recent months
to recall that we hit the debt ceiling
on mid-January and really haven't issued
uh net debt on a net basis since then uh
and so the return of Uncle Sam the
international Capital markets is likely
to coincide with the significant uptick
in coupon issuance from effectively Net
Zero to something that's a lot less a
lot greater than Net Zero in the context
of this uh structural um deep negative
budget deficit so this is in our opinion
it's going to give quantitative
tightening its teeth back as it relates
to potentially draining Bank Reserves
again which is something quantitative
tightening has not done since the
beginning of the year the very you know
kind of middle middle of January so this
is something we're calling out as
potential it's a very likely negative on
impulse on global liquidity in the
coming months let's jump back over to
the Eurozone obviously the liquidity
there they kind of seem to be doing
their own thing to some degree but what
are you seeing on that front yeah so
last week so last week was a big week
right we got the FED on Wednesday the
Eurozone on Thursday China on Thursday
and then um the pprcp we'll see on
Thursday and then obviously the bank of
Japan on a Friday so as it relates to
the Eurozone we got a lot of important
updates as it relates to their liquidity
cycle obviously they hiked interest
rates Madame nagar was extremely hawkish
with respect to the guidance which
allowed terminal uh policy rates um you
know with respect TCB to back up uh
pretty meaningfully week over week last
week and so you know the mark the the
ECB is doing a good job of kind of
pushing through tighter interest rate
expectations through the the kind of
Global Financial system but one thing
that's also they called out last week is
that you know we got 477 billion euros
so over 500 billion dollars of um of of
of of pandemic related financing for
banks that's going to mature uh next
month that they're not going to roll
over so we know the CBS balance sheet is
going to decline by roughly 500 billion
dollars uh next month but we also have
them not no longer reinvesting the
proceeds from their asset purchase
program which is about three trillion
dollars thereabouts and so that's you
know that's it's not quite QT but it's
certainly it's um that balance sheet
runoff is going to be um kind of
negative from the perspective of global
liquidity out of the Eurozone so it's
very likely uh that this is kind of very
modest we're more or less flat you know
this very modest kind of positive
controlling three-month impulse and
Eurozone liquidity is likely to go
negative and get potentially very
negative uh in the coming months you
know particularly around the summer can
you talk about Japan you mentioned them
earlier what's going on with their
liquidity yeah absolutely so Japan is a
kind of an interesting wild card right
so the Japan the bank of Japan stood Pat
on its um yield curve control program
last Friday
um Governor ueda continues to kind of
anchor on wages as opposed to inflation
that's what's really driving that
process but we also know that if you
look at their forecast for um inflation
in Japan particularly for the current
fiscal year they're down at 1.8 percent
whereas you know if you look at where
core CBI is tracking in Japan now it's
about 200 basis points higher than that
and so we know that when we get to July
which is when they're gonna publish
their updated version of you know their
summary of economic projections um the
Japan's version of that it's very likely
they have a significant positive
revision to their inflation forecast now
if that significant positive version to
the current fiscal year inflation
forecast is married by a meaningful
positive revision and out-year inflation
forecast it's very likely that they're
going to have to start you know kind of
you know talking about at the bare
minimum tweaking your career Patrol
again not make I don't know if that we
know enough that they're going to do it
in July but it's certainly something
that could potentially happen in the
coming months you know maybe it happens
in um in September uh thereabouts as it
relates to um you know potentially um
you know kind of change in that program
and why that's relevant for Global
liquidity is because if Japan Alters its
your curve control program it reduces
the amount of pressure that the bank of
Japan will have in terms of defending
the yield Peg uh in in in in Japanese
bond market and ultimately in the global
uh bond market so this is something that
you know you go back to kind of the fall
of last year into the early part of this
year the defense of that Peg was one of
the things that really caused Global
liquidity to the really Spike higher um
you know from Q4 to q1 of this year
right and so ultimately if we don't have
that kind of Market speculation because
the peg is more I guess in line with
global sovereign debt yields then
ultimately you might um you might see
Japan's liquidity impulse uh kind of get
uh incrementally negative in the coming
months so you know when you sum it all
up you have Chinese liquidities going to
be improving we pretty much know with I
wouldn't say so there's no certainty in
financial markets but there's a
reasonable degree of reasonably high
probability that liquidity in the US
gets worse from here over the in the
coming months the euclidity in the
Eurozone gets worse from here in the
coming months and there's a strong
possibility that Japanese liquidity may
get worse in the coming months and so
when you pad up what's happening in the
US and the Eurozone alone it's likely to
offset what we're likely to experience
in China but when they are on Japan
which is obviously a very large economy
and of its own right that may actually
kind of make that offsetting process a
little bit worse and may potentially
cause you know some volatility and asset
markets this summer which has been our
Baseline view
um I don't think this is the end of the
the kind of Bull Run that we've seen
really since um since the fall of last
year because ultimately we still think
the average investor is very much
off-size with respect to the timing of
recession
um you know the two we've been in you
you're not in top of this for a long
time now but we have been since the last
summer of the view that a recession if
it was going to commence in the US
economy that Q4 of 2023 was the highest
probability outcome the second highest
probability outcome of a recession
starting in the U.S economy is q1 of
next year and the reason that's
important as it relates to understanding
the market cycle is that asset markets
tend to squeeze very aggressively into
the end of the business cycle the median
return on the S P 500 if you go back and
look at the 12 recessions post-war
sessions that we have the medium return
to the s p 100 in the year leading up to
the peak in and around the recession is
plus 16 with an interquartile range of
14 to 20 plus 20 14 to plus four plus
twenty percent there are no non-double
digit numbers in that entire 12 cycle
samples so this is a you know with that
understanding we understand that if
we're right on the timing of recession
being Q4 q1 we can see markets rallying
to then in October even January between
now and then so ultimately we do this
correction will be bought uh this summer
if we're right on the liquidity cycle
we're right that we get a correction as
a function of the deep and then you know
kind of adverse liquidity cycle
developments and ultimately you probably
want to buy a dip heading into your end
or maybe even to your Q4 you're in
because ultimately we're not quite ready
for that recession phase two credit
cycle downturn so when you start looking
at that recession
um it's kind of like the most
telegraphed recession of all time right
in terms of like everyone's talking
about everyone's talking about
everyone's waiting for the shoe to drop
whatever is there a scenario where it
couldn't happen What would have to be
the the kind of inputs into that
situation where uh as of right now we
think it's going to happen but what
could change that then gets us in a
situation where we avoid a recession
yeah no it's it's not that what could
change it's that what could continue to
go right
um so you know we've identified sort of
five things that have really contributed
to the resiliency of the US economy and
as a function of that the resiliency of
the US inflation cycle which has caused
obviously a lot more tightening by the
FED since we initially outlined the call
back you know I would say it was August
of last year and so ultimately those two
of those things are you know record cash
on corporate and new record cash on oh
sorry record cash on on household and
corporate balance sheets in the US if
you look at cash checkable deposits as a
share of total assets in uh in the US
for the household sector and the
corporate sectors right around you know
kind of um three percent for each we
haven't seen this High ratio of cash
relative to total assets for both
parties uh since going back to the kind
of mid to late 1960s so that's kind of
what step one
or step two you know you obviously
you've seen a lot of monetary policy
tightening through the lens of the um
the lens of the policy rate and
ultimately that's caused the backup and
bond yields and whatnot but the reality
is
it's just harder for that stuff to
really impact the economy these long and
variable lags may have gotten longer in
the context of how much sort of low cost
fixed rate debt we have in the US
economy right now uh with data through I
want to say q1 of this year the
effective mortgage rate on the you know
total stock of Mortgage Debt in the US
economy is still down to 3.55 obviously
the marginal mortgage rate if you're in
the market to buy a house is you know
north of seven percent but most people
aren't trading their three and a half
percent mortgage to score seven percent
mortgages so it's not the monetary
policy impact of that really is muted
because no one's really moving as a
function of that and so that's kind of
step three uh step four is we've seen
our reason number four is we've seen a
significant decline in manufacturing as
a share of both the labor market and as
a share of GDP you know we used to be I
want to say somewhere around 45 percent
in the 40s in terms of manufacturing as
a share of total employment now we're
down at 14 uh you know we
um manufacturing as a shared GDP is only
18 and the reason this is important is
because Manufacturing if you look at the
net job loss that we experience in
recessions manufacturing on a median
basis is going back to all the post-war
sessions we have data for manufacturing
medium basis accounts for 98 of the net
job loss we tend to see in recession so
that tells you that like hey this is the
cyclical sector of the economy if it is
declined as a share of total employment
and share of GDP obviously you need to
have a much more significant downturn in
the manufacturing sector in the US
economy to actually affect a real
recession across the broader Services
dominated U.S economy and so the final
reason number five is we've seen a
significant amount of Labor hoarding um
in this in this cycle if you sort of
look at the um the Delta between the
current level of this current size of
the total labor force here in the U.S
relative to the pre-covet or the
post-gfc trends but right around five to
six billion million five to six million
workers shy of that trend line so but
well it's not shy the trend line has
been the recovery and gross domestic
incomes we're you know we're north of
that trend line and so we've seen a
significant recovery in income you know
particularly for you know U.S businesses
but we have not seen a significant
recovery in in labor Supply and this is
as a function of that you know you're
seeing a very tight labor market that's
been extremely resilient to Fed
tightening and part of the reason for
that you know being extremely resilient
to Fed tightening is the fact companies
may just be reluctant to fire people in
this particular cycle they may have to
see a significant uh much larger kind of
a hit to their profitability and now
look for their profitability before they
feel comfortable firing people because
they know that in the next business
cycle it's going to be very difficult to
find and retain challenge uh find train
and retain uh Talent so this is
something that's kind of delaying the
process as well
Darius I learned something every time we
talk where can we send people to find
you on the internet or find out more
about 42 macro I appreciate you man so
definitely come check us out at
42macro.com I've obviously put you know
research out for the thought top
institutions asset managers central
banks Etc uh across the global economy
we make that same research available to
retail investors at the same price point
very very low price points because we
ultimately believe that knowledge is
power everyone helps as many people as
we can so check us out at 42 macro and
then we everyone follow us on Twitter as
well my pod my public Twitter is 42
macro weather we have a private Twitter
account as well for our subscribers and
our members so I spend most of my time
in that private account but we
definitely do publish our public account
as well awesome I appreciate it we're
definitely do it again in a couple weeks
absolutely Brothers great to see you
guys cheers